foreign
let's go to
merland uh in Oklahoma what's up Melinda
hey not much how are you Dr John
partying I can't think of a more
Oklahoma name than Orlando that's
fantastic
you should you should
so what's up
well okay so I have a question and in
the grand scheme of everything that's
going on in the world Phil's kind of
like a dumb question wow can I stop you
right there yeah I can almost guarantee
that's part of the problem whatever
you're about to ask me
I I want you to have permission to own
whatever's
bringing you down
okay you promise and I promise and I
might cry Bring it on I might cry with
you
hey
um my question is
sorry
how do I learn to love my body even when
sorry don't hey stop apologizing
you're good same team you're my friend
incredibly over
because I don't love my body okay
when did you I I hate it I hate the way
that I look okay how long have you
struggled with your weight
um my whole life
I'm um
I'm a twin a fraternal twin and
fraternal twin is we all grew up super
skinny and I knew from a comparison age
like whenever I first started noticing
that we looked different
um I was the bigger one and actually was
dubbed that as a child like
just at basketball games my friends my
family you know I'm I'm the bigger twin
so my whole life
so most of us who have struggled with
what we see in the mirror
who take her shirts off and look in the
mirror are grossed out and I've put my
I'll put myself in that category I've
talked about that here
um
we have an imaginary idea of what we
would look like in another body or if we
would finally just start taking care of
ourselves and stop being so lazy or
whatever other crap we put on a piling
ourselves
you walked alongside a literal person
popular girl who was pretty and and I
love her she's my best friend and she
knows all of these things
um
but I I even remember Dr John like at a
young age asking her and then I actually
so I have a twin and then I have a
younger sister that's just 16 months
younger so we were pretty much like
triplets
um and she again was skinny tall popular
pretty athletic and I I remember like
probably Junior High asking them
repeatedly like hey are are you
embarrassed of me like
do I embarrass you or do I
um you know do you want do you want to
be seen with me like unprompted would
just ask them that you know of course
they'd be like we don't care like you're
you like you're fine but in my mind
um I was less than yeah
yeah and I still like I I still feel
that way and I and like today's culture
you know like it's
like something that and this has been
more recently like I I have found like
these inadvertent thoughts of comparison
um you watch a commercial you know like
and and I've noticed like there's not
very many fat people in that commercial
you know like or I I'm also I'm a
worship pastor
um so that's always fun because we live
stream services so you know I there's a
video every week of that I if I would
allow myself I go back and watch and I
can critique myself
um but like even
in the realm that I'm in just watching
different videos there's I I find myself
looking for people who look like me and
realizing
like there's not and and I don't know if
um people do that consciously or
unconsciously but
I immediately do the comparison game and
like okay well that's because you're
you're you you're your lifespan yeah so
let's
um
I want you to imagine I'm holding your
hand okay because I want to walk through
a few things and it's going to be
uncomfortable for a minute until it gets
the other side is that okay
absolutely okay
um and I'm going to use some intentional
I'm gonna say things in a in a less than
um
then my normally I try to be pretty
careful with my language I'm going to be
intentional about some things is that
okay absolutely
um I want you to give me some words that
come to mind when you think of fat
people
the judgments you make just let them
rattle off the top of your head go
yep
we're already in it now I I know I know
I'm trying to say well my voice doesn't
shake um unattractive
ugly
um
less than like in this as far as like
not as productive not as efficient okay
um people don't like people don't
respect you as much okay
um you want more here here we could and
if you and I were sitting down together
yeah because here's here's what I want
you to put out put out there I do think
you don't like your body I don't make
any mistake about that
I'll even go as far as to say I believe
you that you hate your body
but you hate Miranda
in those words you used to describe all
those other people or the words you use
that's the stories you tell yourself
and I'll also go with you that those are
stories you inhabited that was the air
you breathed that you're the big girl
you're the one and there's a reality to
that you have a different you have a
different genetic makeup your body's
different than your twin sister
right right so you you ha there's a
reality to that and
there was a narrative that you are the
this one and you were one of them not
one of them
to the point that as a young kid
most kids can be so unaware that they're
different
you were not
so somebody somewhere is making it
pretty pretty clear
not 100 and so that story over time
those stories from the kids from your
parents from that Aunt that's just like
oh honey you shouldn't eat that like all
that when you're six for God's sake
all of that those stories
they become stories you tell yourself in
your own voice
and I agree I learned this in a heavy
conversation if you haven't heard my
interview with Sal de Stefano I had him
on my show a while back he's one of the
Mind pump guys
one of the heaviest conversations I've
had around this topic and he said
something that um
I got choked up on the on the interview
because I never occurred to me
he said John you cannot hate yourself
you can't hate your body into better
shape
you can't go to the gym
and try to get rid of how disgusting you
are
you can't look at healthy food and shove
it down your throat because you are so
grossed out by
it doesn't work like that it's a recipe
for Crash and Burn
so it's probably for yo-yo dieting
because that's what I've done my whole
life yes and you know how you can yo-yo
diet because you're
one of the strongest people around
you can grit your teeth
because you're strong you've had to be
your whole life
you're real strong you can grit your
teeth and you can lose 30 pounds but you
still hate Miranda
yep
and so it's what we're looking for here
is less about how do I not hate my body
it's how do I make peace with Miranda
and when I decide to go work out
I'm giving Miranda a gift because I love
her
when I decide to not go Crush another
box of whatever which was me last night
I bought seven seven boxes of uh Girl
Scout cookies those evil kids who sell
them one month after everyone's New
Year's resolution
um
but I didn't dominate him last night
based on a conversation I had with Lane
Norton who said hey
you
it's a story you're telling yourself
that you can't help yourself yeah you
can and John my friend is worth more
than that and when he's told me those
words it was like a light bulb came on
and right I do this for a living I've
been having this conversation for 30
years and here I am now
oh yeah I can't hate myself into
long-term Behavior change I gotta love
myself that way
same as you can't hate and nag your
husband or wife or girlfriend or
boyfriend into changing it doesn't work
right right so
tell me two or three things that merland
is really amazing at
um contrary to my own my own beliefs I'm
a really good leader
um I am okay can I stop you right there
yeah can we agree on the outset that
your beliefs about yourself are
inaccurate often
100 sweet all right cool that's usually
like seven or eight sessions right there
that's fantastic okay so you know that
your feeling signals can be off or they
can be wrong which is awesome okay so
you're great at worship leading does
that mean you're a great singer a great
guitarist or you're great at bringing
people into community
bringing people in the community awesome
not just like on stage but like in I can
think of few gifts greater to humanity
than someone who can rally people
together for a common purpose good for
you what else
um
I'm very very kind and caring for other
people
um
I've become
I don't know why is this so hard in
every the negative things are so easy
well because our brains are wired for
him and you've had a steady stream of
negativity dumped into your heart mind
your whole life
and negative things are what get us
killed not the positive stuff so our
brains are wired to look for the
negative because it doesn't want to die
yeah and that means we have to work
really hard especially in this world
with all the cell phones and all the
attention and all the video streams that
you're on every week that when our brain
is going there's a threat there's a
threat there's a threat we also have to
counter that with and there's joy and
there's laughter
and there's somebody who's working to
really love herself after a long time of
not having a road map for what that
looks like
yeah here's a way a place I want you to
start
a couple of things number one
I want you to start treating my friend
Miranda like you treat those people at
your church
you're kind to them
you welcome them
you laugh and when they say I screwed up
this and I can't believe I slept with so
and so and I did this you say oh my gosh
I love you
and I want you to treat Miranda like
that
and what that means is that's a morning
practice and an evening practice and
you're gonna have to do it double time
because you've been on this track for on
another set of tracks for a long time
I love Miranda because
and don't make a logistical sorry yeah
go ahead like you mean like I'm a
logistics person and I tell it to like
one of my small group classes a lot like
Go Get It Go Get a journal today from
the store a brand new one that you've
never written in before
okay
and then and I would put swear words in
it if I wasn't talking to a worship
leader but at the top I would put
why Miranda is worth loving
no not even that Miranda is worth loving
period how about that Miranda I'm sorry
Miranda's worth loving period
and then underneath it write down
Orlando is somebody who treats people
with dignity and respect Miranda is
somebody who is loved
Miranda is someone who keep going and by
the way you're going to start seeing
that a lot of the stuff is Performance
Based about what you can do for other
people
I want you to get beneath that
is that like part of it because that is
like as you were asking what's you know
what are the things that I'm good at I
mean I
I a hundred percent or I would not 100
but probably 97 of all the things that I
think that I'm good at is how I can make
other people's lives better that's
because your whole life you've always
felt worthless and not pretty and not
worthy of being talked to or looked at
or set with and so you created a world
where you could go out
and act your way into worth and value
and God Miranda that's exhausting isn't
it
yes it is
in your spot on it's exhausting
here's the second thing I want you to do
and this is going to be the most
annoying challenge okay and you're gonna
have to practice this
if you and I started salsa dancing
classes we would be terrible right
right and we would know that because we
had never taken salsa dancing before and
we would laugh and stumble around and
fall and our instructor would be like
ah get out of my class and then we'd pay
him and he'd be like all right you can
come back it'd be a whole thing
so as you're practicing this new thing I
wanna I'm gonna get this new task I want
to give you give yourself Grace you
don't know what you're doing you've
never done this before
okay it's gonna be a lot of stumbling
and falling and tripping and it's okay
because it's all new and you'll be like
oh man I screwed that one up have that
attitude about it not well there's
another thing I can put in the Miranda
sucks pile okay
I want you to carry this journal around
with you
everywhere and by the way I got one
right here on my desk right now okay I
want you to carry it around with you
and when you have a negative thought
about Miranda write it down
every single time it's like taking a
budget except for your thoughts
like you know like you have apps like I
use the every dollar app to for my
expenses and every time I buy something
it shows up and it reminds me you just
spent this you just spent this I want
you to do that with your thoughts
because what we have to do in real quick
order is take capture of our thoughts
the things that are circling in your
mind all day you're going to be stunned
and how often you walk by a mirror and
think I'm disgusting or gross or why'd I
wear this shirt or when you're watching
yourself and there could be a thousand
people in your church
being led through a pretty remarkable
worship service and all you can see when
you're watching the tape back is how
unattractive you think you look
I want you to write all of that down and
here's the second part of that write it
down and challenge that is this true
and most of the time the answer is no
now I'm also going to tell you hard
truth is this is it okay
look at a photo of yourself or you walk
by the mirror and you think the words I
need to lose weight you probably do
but not to be loved
not so that you finally have value
but because you're worth getting up and
your back not hurting and your knees not
hurting and you feeling recklessly
beautiful and you live in to be 80 years
old so you can continue to bring people
together in joy and love and comfort
is that fair
absolutely
yes and so become like I said exercise
becomes a gift
becomes an awesome thing that you give
Miranda taking like working with
somebody to change how you eat all that
stuff like that becomes a gift it
doesn't become a burden or a chore it's
an annoying gift I don't like all my
gifts but it's a gift
it's definitely felt like punishment of
course my whole life because you hate
you and you deserve to be punished
foreign
Orlando that stops today
same team
thank you
will you reach out and call somebody in
your area and tell them
I've hated myself for the last time
yes
okay
anything I'll be with you every step of
the way okay and again I want you to
hear me say this this isn't a weight
loss Journey
this is going to be a Journey about
rediscovering Miranda and finally giving
that little girl a voice
finally let that little girl know that
she's loved and valued even though she
doesn't look like her sister
and here's another honest take you may
need to get with a doctor they have had
some advancements in
um obesity care that is unimaginable ten
years ago
it's incredible
yeah okay see I thought about those
things and it's made me think oh well
it's just because you're weak even
though like I've completed 75 hard and I
could do a crossfit workout and I
haven't had sweets since November 1st
like I haven't had any candy or like I
could do things hard things but in my
mind I that's negative thoughts just
start
derailing you can do some hard things
but you can't do the ultimate hard thing
yet
ultimate hard thing is forgiving Miranda
for hating herself for so long and
deciding today I'm gonna go do something
different
I took anxiety medication for a couple
of years and it saved my life
and I don't recommend people take
medicine
and I sat at my kitchen table and I wept
I felt like such a freaking loser
and anxiety medication did not cure me
but it did
give me the opportunity to start doing
the things that would heal me
sit down with the doctor and going
through whether it's medication or
whether so there's all kinds of
different paths here and don't let any
nonsensical influencer or on
YouTube
that's between you and your doctor and
your physician okay
you're not weak you just happen to live
in a sliver of history when we have some
of the most extraordinary advancements
in the history of mankind that can help
people in our situation
and our situations are different
Fair no fair that makes sense though
starting today you like Miranda and
you're nice to Miranda like I like
Miranda is that fair
deal thank you for being one of the
bravest people I've talked to in a long
long time
anything I can do along the way anytime
you want to call back and say I'm stuck
here I need some help here holler at me
can walk alongside you so grateful for
you